I just saw the documentary citizen 4
about Edward Snowden which is a
real-life thriller it takes you from the
moment the snowden reaches out to
journalists with NSA documents to now
Snowden risked everything to tell the
world about what the NSA was doing and
yet he says that his greatest fear was
that nothing would change and even
though Obama has talked about reining in
the NSA and there are ongoing lawsuits
against the NSA so far that fear has
come true my name is Edward Snowden I go
by ahead and for me one of the craziest
things about the film is to see how
quickly the US government moves in on
Snowden and the journalists who are
trying to tell his story which basically
proves Snowden's point u.s. surveillance
is global and total but it's not the
first of its kind and it's worth it to
look at how other governments have also
heavily spied on their own people
take for example East Germany in the 50s
60s 70s and 80s they had a secret police
called the Stasi there was one Stasi
informant for every 63 people they
tapped phones put cameras in people's
apartments sprayed their floors with
radiation so they could track their
every footstep they even trained dogs to
sniff people out based on their stolen
dirty underwear when Stasi files were
finally released one of the first people
to read their own file was a guy named
Roland Yan who discovered that his
friends were informing on him and that
his eight-year-old daughter was followed
to school
it all seems ridiculous now because the
key to tracking anyone so closely is
right in their pockets you've got a
camera a microphone all your personal
data you even have a GPS locator but why
would anyone want all that information
well the Nazis for example would have
loved it according to a history
professor that I spoke with the Nazis
were interested in spying on the German
people to get their quote attitudes and
moods so they could gauge their own
popularity it was way harder back then
to get location data and yet the Nazis
had two million index cards full of
people's names
addresses mostly of a people polish
workers gypsies and of course Jews so
that when the time came they can easily
find them and arrest them they also
attract people's mail just like the NSA
both paper and now electronic except the
difference of course is quantity every
day the NSA collects 1.7 billion pieces
of electronic communications and every
second it adds terabytes and terabytes
of metadata to giant information
storehouses that it has around the world
the Stasi could only tap 40 phones at
any given time so yeah while we're not
living in East Germany we probably have
less privacy than any other generation
ever has and it's amazing how easily
that information can be used against you
at the drop of a hat as soon as the
state decides for whatever reason that
you are a threat and those index cards
last forever and they can be searched
retro actively but doesn't the
Constitution protect Americans well you
would think except we've also got our
friend the Patriot Act that has
challenged the Fourth Amendment which is
your right not to have your goods or
your stuff searched or taken without a
warrant not to mention the idea that
you're being spied on or could be spied
on might change what you talk about who
you talk about it with what you read
where you hang out who you hang out with
basically your First Amendment rights
the other thing we've learned from
history is that people living in
surveillance States often accept the
fact that they're being spied on but
given what we know now should we